it's the tenth season of Kirby still
interested still enjoying it I love it
Larry and I take our job seriously but
we laugh all day good up all day yeah I
would think it would be I mean just even
working in comedy all these years I can
tell that's a set where people are
having fun we have a ball I mean I'm so
honored and always excited about going
to work and yeah I love it and I love
where if you've started watching this
year you have no idea where the whole
Speight store thing is going crazy yeah
we have a plenty of you have not seen it
I can tell by your reaction but that's
okay
that's the Goldberg no or better than
that if you're worth the camera
whichever here is like tens if you don't
have this one thing I love Conan I love
this show but right now turn over to
Netflix and watch our man in Chicago
starring me my stand-up special you
don't need to see me now you can watch
this another time maybe just just like
two more minutes here and then switch on
over
[Applause]
almost done I completely agree concur
he concurs two more minutes it's no Mike
shows not going I also want to make sure
I mentioned we have a clip here from
curb which it should show and I think
what we need to say is this is you and
Larry just yelling to each other okay
let me see what it is it's all we needed
I won't even take a look let's take a
look I'm fantastic dishwasher did you
know that I could put my hands in in
boiling scalding water and I don't feel
anything
I don't need gloves let me see those
hands I'm really good you've never
washed a dish in your life well I
haven't watched him in a while you've
watched somebody else oh I can be very
special I'll stick him on any hot water
you can find okay that's insane yeah
when we filmed those scenes Larry laughs
yeah yeah and we have to start over
right right right I'm a pro he's very
unprofessional I want to mention too
that you have a photography exhibit it's
not graffiti and the way I've been doing
it for years and the first time I've let
anybody see them it's at the Leica
gallery here in Los Angeles and every
Saturday at 1:00 I give a tour but it's
open every day and there's no charge go
see that cuz I've known you for years
and you're always carrying a camera I've
taken pictures here with you yeah yeah
I'm suing you for it